Okay, let's go to your voicemail.
Uh, voicemails can be left at two one nine
two.
David P, here's an interesting little question.
Take a listen.
Hello David.
My name is Isaac.
I'm calling because I wanted to know what
you thought about whether or not if the coronavirus,
uh, outbreak, which is a pandemic level, would
that, um, be good for Trump's reelection prospects?
Yeah, I, I don't know the answer to that.
Pandemic means worldwide spread of a new disease.
Uh, this is certainly a new strain of a type
of disease that we are familiar with.
Um, if it, if Corona virus becomes a pandemic,
I genuinely have no idea whether it is or
is not good for Trump.
We already saw Trump hypocritically changing
his position, um, uh, on coronavirus to one
that is very different from what he was tweeting
when Barack Obama was dealing with Ebola back
in 2014.
I don't know the answer I want to hear from
you.
Is a coronavirus pandemic good or bad for
Trump?
But of course, either way, uh, we want to
do everything we can to stop the spread of
coronavirus.
I will likely have updated numbers for you
on its spread, um, probably on tomorrow's
program.
Let me know what you think.
Uh, on the bonus show today, Harvey Weinstein
has been found guilty and immediately complained
of chest pains and was, uh, instead of being
brought to Rikers where he was remanded until
sentencing on March 11th, he was brought to
the hospital.
Instead, we will talk about what's going on
with Harvey Weinstein.
We will talk about a new, what is effectively
a wealth test for immigrants that Donald Trump
has put into effect.
It's a rule that is a de facto wealth test.
You want to come to the United States.
And lastly, Ponzi schemes have hit their highest
level in a decade.
This is actually an indicator led a possible
leading indicator about what we may expect
in the stock market in coming years.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show, get instant access by becoming a member@joinpacman.com
I'll speak to you then and hope to see you
tonight on the live stream for the South Carolina
democratic presidential debate, Twitch, YouTube,
and Facebook live.
Starting about 45 minutes before the debate.
I'll see you that the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].